and the spirit award for best female
lead goes to
carrie mulligan for promising young
woman
oh my goodness thank you so much the
spirit
that's amazing um i'm
shocked and in awe and honored to be in
this group of extraordinary
women and and so flawed by each and
every one of their performances so
um thank you for being uh in their
company to be recognized amongst them is
such an honour
um i need to just thank first and
foremost emerald fennell
for her complete genius in writing uh
and directing and producing this work to
our
extraordinary crew i always think
independent film is so much fun because
you get to do it in 28 days or 29 days
and it's so much fun to be
on summer camp with people um but i
think a 23-day shoot for the crew
is just grueling and they were
painstakingly
thoughtful and and careful and
beautifully sensitive with each and
every scene and i'm just so grateful to
them and to our cast
and to margot robbie and lucky chap and
film nation and focus features
um and there's so many other people to
thank um but my mind is blank from fear
um but i just want to dedicate this
award to a true
independent spirit and actress that i
have
looked up to and will continue to look
up to um for the rest of my career
um helen mccrory so thank you to her for
everything she
gave us and thank you again for this